[Music]
wrapping up our time here in atlanta in
advance of the soup bowl and look at
ryan shea's here my good that's more
than i can lift yes it is that's a lot
more than i can i probably couldn't lift
the bar how much is that on there ryan
uh that's about 135 145 yeah no it's not
i mean he can't he still he could never
do that in his prime there's no way and
and he is the great ryan chazier he
joins us here now on set at the super
bowl right and we've talked in the past
we talked before your injury i haven't
had a chance to talk to you since then
and and what you've gone through and how
you've handled yourself with grace and
dignity it's an inspiration to so many
people who are dealing with any type of
adversity regardless of whether it's a
similar injury just anything they're
dealing with any disease any problem any
issue to see how you've handled yourself
is a credit to you and your family and
it's an inspiration to so many people
and i've been waiting to tell you that
for a long time but you know we feel for
you for what happened to you but we love
how you've handled yourself and what it
means to other people legend status like
seriously can make me cry honestly i'm
not even gonna lie thank you so much
thank you so much and it's great that
the steelers
have you working in that organization
because there is value in having ryan
chazier around learning the ropes in the
scouting department learning the ropes
in the coaching department you could be
and you already are a valuable member of
that family but i think for years to
come we're having ryan chazier as part
of the steelers i mean there's already
that sense that you are a steeler and
you always will be a steeler and i think
you could you could mean so much to
helping shape the young lives of the men
that that come through the organization
so it's great to hear that you're doing
that as well yeah i love that they're
keeping me involved and uh the people
there the the
the team and the franchise they've just
been uh handling the situation great
also and i just truly thank them and
just allowing me to be a part of it
allow me just to stay connected and i
really feel like it's helping me but
it's also helping them so
take us through that night okay just
like and i don't mean to but i i mean
i'm just like what was everything going
through your head you're playing the
bangles of course and i mean even just
yeah just everything just so it was it
was
actually a crazy day because uh i could
actually pretty much remember the whole
day just kind of weird and the one thing
is i don't have the best memories but so
i can remember pretty much most of the
things that happened throughout that
whole day and the biggest thing about
that week was i had hurt my ankle the
week before so it was like the whole
week i didn't practice right uh and i
was up in the air if i really wanted to
play and i was like man this is gonna be
the one season i can go the whole year
i'm not missing the game yeah you know
and i have her ankle but i'm not missing
the game and uh
and everything seemed fine you know i
was playing i actually started off the
game really well i had about two or
three tackles on the first drive and
whenever i'm having those type of games
i'm like oh here we go it's gonna be a
good game man honestly it was just like
a regular a regular play
and honestly this is the one time out of
my whole career i was like hey let me
actually try to focus on like trying to
put my head across or whatever let me
try to actually focus on like just not
making a tackle like try to you know
were you aiming for the ball with your
head right no he's like
you're trying to get your head across
his body yeah so like i think i don't
know i think that made me like extend a
little bit extra or whatever and i end
up getting behind him instead of in
front and i hit my hip hip head right on
his hip right yes
and then from that moment it's like i i
just
woke up a little bit i didn't like black
all the way out but i just opened my
eyes and
from that moment it's just like
it's it's like like my life changed
immediately and i just you know they
tell you that things can change
immediately but it just you never think
it could happen like that i've been
there so just say yeah i mean i've been
there cause i lost my spleen and i
almost died playing football i mean it's
so i i feel you and everything it's
amazing how aware you can be in those
things and the things you do remember we
spent a lot of time trying to figure out
what's wrong with the steelers and what
they need to do to to improve and get
back to
competing for super bowls and one thing
that really comes up they don't have
ryan chazier anymore yeah i mean how big
of a factory do you think it is for this
team in 2018 to not have your presence
on the field the leadership you bring
and everything that you meant to that
defense to have that gone i think that's
one of the biggest factors that we all
have overlooked when we try to figure
out what's gone wrong with the steelers
honestly
it definitely hurt that i wasn't there
but i try to be there as much as i can
as a
coach or a leader or friend and try to
get them as much as advice as i could
but i i understand that uh
without me out there it kind of did play
a role you know i was able to help make
a lot of turnovers or make some splash
plays uh when i was out there and i
understand that sometimes we didn't have
those as much as we would like so it
definitely was tough for me i know it
was tough for some of the other guys
because sometimes they'll even come to
me during the game
so undeniably dairy we have a campaign
going on and it's uh it's pretty much
just letting everybody know that we have
a lot of local farmers out here and it's
it's great just to know where your
food's coming from and how we have a lot
of hard-working farmers out here just
giving you your food day to day and just
good to know where your food's coming
from yeah i like it man i'm all about
organic local i really do so that's a
great cause i mean it couldn't be better
hey real quick we've had juju here
cameron hayward was here it seems like
nobody can get in touch with antonio
brown have you had any luck tracking
them down i text them a little bit but
it's just when i text people about that
type of stuff i don't really try to talk
too much about what everybody else is
talking about about the media i just try
to see how their family he respond to
you uh he takes me back with like a
thumbs up he doesn't like
uh he's dealing with a lot and i just
want to see him happy man all right last
30 seconds
okay we got 30 seconds pick it up read
it let's go i'm gonna pick it for you
all right you gotta it's random okay
who plays you in a movie oh
man
that's a tough one it's between denzel
have to shave his head
yeah
between will smith
the rock you know
you know the rock yeah you know uh i
don't know if he was the best football
player but you know he's a good actor
especially like i think he has some
enhanced muscles though okay hey man if
they got me running through walls
on my movie i'm cool with that all right
cool all right hey ryan it's great
seeing you we wish you all the best
going forward hope to talk to you again
soon we'll be back with kyle shanahan
coach of the 49ers right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports